- Let's figure out what percentage
of a benzene molecule by mass
is made up of the carbons,
and what percentage is
made up by the hydrogens.
And as we see, each molecule of benzene
has six carbons and six hydrogens in it.
And I encourage you to
pause the video now,
and use a periodic table,
we'll be a little bit more
precise in this video,
we'll use the actual atomic weight
to calculate the molecular mass,
or you should say the molecular weight
of a benzene molecule, and then figure out
what percentage of that is from carbons,
and what percentage of
that is from hydrogens.
So I'm assuming you
have had your go at it,
so let's first think about what percentage
is from the carbons, or let's see
what the carbon contributes to the mass.
So you have six carbons, so the C six
is going to be six times, and if we get
our periodic table out, we see that
the atomic weight of carbon, is 12.011,
so the weighted average
of all the isotopes
as found on Earth, and we've
talked a lot about that,
12.011 atomic mass units,
this is going to be
and the contribution from hydrogen,
the contribution from hydrogen,
let me do that in yellow...
The contribution from hydrogen,
from the six hydrogens, is going to be six
times the atomic weight of hydrogen,
which is 1.0079, by this periodic table
that I have right here, once again,
the weighted average of all the isotopes,
et cetera, et cetera, 1.0079.
1.0079, and so, the molecular weight
of this whole thing, a
typical benzene molecule,
if you were to take the weighted average
of all of its molecular masses,
based on the prevalence
of the different isotopes
on Earth, well, you would just say
it's just going to be the
sum of these two things.
It is going to be six times 12.011
plus, six times 1.0079, and then what
is that going to give us?
Well, let's see, let's
get a calculator out,
so let me clear that, so 12.011
times six gives us 72.066,
so this right over here.
is 72.066, and actually, I probably
could have done that in my head,
well anyway, let's look at what we have
from the hydrogen, so the hydrogen
are going to be six times 1.0079
gets us to 6.0474, plus 6.0474,
now we're going to add them together,
but since I only go to
the thousandth place
in terms of precision here,
if I care about significant figures,
significant digits, then I'm only going
to go three spaces to
the right of the decimal,
but let's add these two together,
so I'm going to get 6.0474, plus 72.066
equals, and I'm just going
to go three to the right,
so 78.113, so this is equal to,
78.113 atomic mass units,
that's the molecular mass
of a molecule of benzene,
now what percentage
is from the carbon? Well, it's going
to be equal to the 72.066 over the 78.113
which is equal to, all right,
so let me just clear this.
So 72.066 divided by 78.113 is equal to
0.9225, it keeps going on and on and on,
but in terms of percentages,
this is going to be, and let's say
I want to keep my precision,
so I have five significant digits in both
the numerator and the denominator,
so I can have five significant digits
in the answer, so it's not .92259,
.92259 if I were to round this eight up,
because I have this six here.
So this is 0.92259 which is,
let me see, this is approximately equal
to since I'm now rounding,
and this is equal
to 92.259 percent carbon.
Now, the remainder is
going to be hydrogen,
of course we can figure that out,
that's going to be 6.0474
divided by the 78.113,
which is going to get us,
so let me clear it out.
So 6.0474 divided by 78.113,
is equal to 0.07741, and let's see
I have five significant
digits in either case,
so this is going to be, 0.07742.
0.07742, did I do that right?
I have trouble remembering these numbers.
Let's see, 0.0774, and
then I round that one up
because I have an eight
in the next place over,
so four, two, which if
I were to express as
a percentage, and this is
five significant digits
right here, one, two, three, four, five,
as a percentage is equal to,
and this is roughly, since I'm rounding,
this is going to be 7.742 percent,
and these roughly do
add up to 100 percent.
So most of the mass here,
even though you have an
equal number of carbons
and hydrogens, most of the mass here
is from the carbons, and a little over
92 percent of the mass
is from the carbons.